good morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast
good morning millenials how are we doing
today on this wonderful Thursday we're
getting there
chugging along very slowly in a really
hard week for a short week that's what
we were talking about it's like in the
past couple days I've watched clips of
the toast later in the day and been like
I could have done better you could and
that's upsetting maybe if I wasn't so
goddamn tired like I could have done
better so I'm like trying today maybe
maybe exhaustion is just a mental
construct it's a social contract I love
saying things or social constructs
accept someone in the casino in where oh
your bachelorette party and the Mamas
told me they're like what do you do I
was like but it's like waiting for
someone to ask me just so I could be
like I'm a comic comedy is a social
construct no finances okay that's so
crazy you know what I realize is a
social contract this will shake you to
your core wait let me think
no you're not gonna get okay I don't
even know what but home your home is a
social construct right because anywhere
could really be your home but you've
just made it your home because it's like
but anywhere can't be your home because
if I walked into a mansion on Fifth
Avenue they would be like get anywhere
like you couldn't make your home I like
the feeling of being home yeah is a
social construct but it's not a social
contract it's actually a personal
concept to construct yeah it's a
construct yes and when they teach you
like in English class this is a social
contract what examples do they use like
what is the classic example of a social
construct I don't you know yeah like I
don't know I think if we're to tie it
well how do we go from like being tired
to talking about social conscious that's
the thing about social their social and
they're constructed constructed well
Jackie and I are obviously going to
deliver past five today but what else oh
my god I went to a sporting event last
night right you did and just like Ben is
always doing stuff with me and for me
that like I enjoy so every now and then
I have to do the same and I just like it
was actually a good game like usually
the Knicks are so bad it's like halfway
through you know they're not gonna win
they're trailing behind so much but to
the very end
it was a buzzer-beater situation and it
was like great and all that but it's
just like the getting up and getting
dressed and going down to the seats up
to the bathroom down to the drink it's
just like so much physically strenuous
Edward yeah work that like I was
exhausted afterwards like we get to I
need to get food and I literally ate
protein like I thought I was gonna die
and I check how many steps you did oh
yeah I was like I don't have a pedometer
but then I realized hold on let me check
but like did I have my phone yeah I did
yeah man how kind of protein did you
have chicken teriyaki all right really
protein so overall you had a good time
what day is it today am I gonna haven't
checked my steps Wednesday member it was
Wednesday yesterday and you probably did
it on the show too
okay what do you think I did yesterday
yeah 5500 okay that makes me feel less
bad 4,000 oh I was like that's not a lot
no it's not but there were so many steps
I got to see just like no celebrity it's
like that was annoying
except you know who's there Alec and
Billy Baldwin and you want to hear
something interesting Ben was like I
can't believe like they're still like
after everything alec has done like he's
not cancelled and as he said it they put
him on screen and not one person cheered
I think I actually heard boos really
yeah it was really awkward good and then
they put the kid from stranger things
and like everyone was eyeing the Verizon
FiOS kid know one of the other ones like
one of the less famous but Susan hosts
famous works for me ya know and make it
was those little games that they play
between like timeouts and stuff like
that's my jam oh my god and then they
had a halftime show
at a game it was the funniest thing ever
like he was took the whole court as his
stage literally like he was dancing
around with the Knicks City Dancers he
has so many bingers I didn't realize but
like I've never it was just like a weird
setting for a halftime show you know
sure I didn't know they did have to pay
jobs for low-level NBA games but it was
obviously like he wanted tickets so
they're like well will you sing he set
like today's national anthem Oh some
talented ass [ __ ]
usually like I sit and watch a national
anthem and I'm like are they kidding me
like I could be doing this so much
better but you know what I'm not gonna
lie like I was intimidated by this girl
like she was really good that's good
who's that is like my goal of 2019 to
sing the national anthem
even I like a minor league whatever like
just let me get my foot in the door and
I would die like and something for you
are you yeah
is that my birthday gift no no it's just
like I've Chief connects yeah you do
yeah you will be singing that song I
don't know when but in your life okay in
my life who's acting yeah you know I
have a little problem with a key I just
gotta find my key can you see this girl
was so busy she was doing like all sorts
of trills up there and I was just like I
was humble do you know yeah I heard by
her talent that's good that's rarely
happens to you yeah and you know I feel
like it's an artist it's good every now
and then to feel modest for sure well
anyways it's Thursday it's raining here
in New York City oh my god do came back
from his morning walk like a wet noodle
covered in dirt and it was honestly so
[ __ ] annoying I was running so late
and I had to give him a bath I was
actually thinking about the oh when I
walked in this morning I was like house
Theo handling this weather cuz imagine
going in the bathroom and getting rained
on this imagine relaxing experience
mother nature has absolutely no respect
for our four-legged friends but how is
Theo doing after his headlining
performance at Knott's Berry Farm
um he's exhausted obviously you know it
takes an emotional toll on him just to
be a performer but also to be present
and you know connect with his fans but
his fans are really important to him
because they're who made him what he is
so he's extremely grateful for all the
attention for the opportunities can you
see his prescription pad I need but not
my decision of joy of joy I really need
to up my dosage of joy I've been like
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] these days and you
don't look you hang out with doing like
you go to camp and I call you and your
camp burns like you speak your own
language yeah and like you like when you
get back to school like you can't stop
talking like your friends like I
remember one summer I was in a bunk up
girls like all we did was like talk like
this so like will you pass the shampoo
and I would get back wonder who started
back and when I got back like I couldn't
stop doing it well when I was in Mexico
like I was hanging out all my friends
from Mexico and like they talk a certain
way and like it's really vulgar so like
I was on the phone with Margo and like I
said the most disgusting thing to my
little sister like I can't believe I
said it then I was like oh my god I have
to get my like my Mexico lingo out of
here I'll tell you later I can't even
say it
oh god okay cool I said never I thought
I was in on the joke
but no no no I thought I was a part of
the story it's like no I don't know it
was like we talked like we all have our
own language and like you don't really
have to say much like just so you say
dad for scenes and I hear you yeah and
then you go out with your friends and
it's like oh I have to carry a
conversation and I can't just say I'm
dead for scenes enjoy your translator -
everyone will leave me alone yeah no no
no it's tough being both a lexicon of
information while also needing to be a
translator I love being a lexicon you
too
okay are you ready wait are you ready
for the FASFA
are you ready for what for the fast side
stories that you need stun before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast hmm let me think okay okay
yeah we gotta get into it I feel like
the Tin Man I need some oil you know I
just feel so um rusty rusty dick oh my
god rusty dick
oh speaking of rusty dick we have Ryan
heard on the show tomorrow
country singer to the stars Maron mrs.
Marin Morris mr. Monroe Morris he'll be
here tomorrow and if you have any
questions we'll be posting a social card
on our Instagram so feel free to drop a
little comment there
I'm excited it's been a while since
we've had an artiste on the show no I'm
like a true artiste yeah Oh a night for
me and I want to talk that's true I want
to talk to him because he did a cover of
dress by Taylor Swift at one of his
shows and it was really good I just
wanna be like what inspired that well
now hit the Martha heard Morris family
are now friends at the Swift family
right cuz Maren performed in Dallas with
her interesante yeah really good first
story I saw last night and I just have
so many thoughts Vinny Guadagnino begs
Kim Kardashian to help free Mike
Sorrentino oh my god me and Ben we're
talking about this at dinner last night
it is so [ __ ] stupid Vinny Guadagnino
was calling in the big guns to get
Jersey Shore pal Mike the situation
Sorrentino sprung from prison where did
you guys go to dinner by the way second
he sushi looks so good on instantly were
dying we had to be rolled out we ate so
much
there was one roll that looked so good I
left smelling what I always usually ask
him where he went but then I figured you
guys were together so I would find out
yeah that's good no I usually um no no
sorry not usually I like after my meal
last night I was eating so fast I
literally started sweating and just like
being in like the Japanese restaurant
like I started to smelt like I literally
smell like sesame oil and you know I
didn't shower just like sprayed some
perfume in my
maybe you turn into Freaky Friday like
oh my god I give it up fortune cookie
and then at midnight the clock strikes
12:00 and I become bed oh my god I would
have the best time being man except I
would have to like work yeah I don't the
best time being been on the weekends
he's so much energy that's true no but I
have started like speaking of Jersey
Shore the Jersey Shore shower
I've stopped showering and just I just
started praying spit spraying perfume in
my hair and now that I have the little
travel-size perfumes from Sandburg I'd
throw them in my bag and like it's
really stopped me from showering like
tenfold and I have to be honest I
haven't noticed well that's good cuz
temporary it's a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes a way for you to discover new
perfumes and colognes without buying an
entire bottle basically they said you
like pint sized sizes of like a really
expensive perfumes that last you a month
and then the next month you get more
like it's so great so we have an
exclusive offer for our listeners you
can get 50% off your first month today
that's only seven dollars and fifty
cents for your first fragrance go to
scent bird dot-com slash toast and use
our code toast for 50% off your first
month again that's scent bird SC EMT BIR
d.com slash toast for you to try your
first perfume or cologne for just seven
dollars and fifty cents sign on smell
amazing
I [ __ ] love Sanford and I want to be
one of those people I'm not there yet
who has like a scent and you can like
smell them walk into their friend Danny
yeah she has said you know your husband
has the scent e a scent of all time I
dunno and like I'll be walking in the
street and someone might be wearing that
product alone and I'm like no or I'll be
at a party like I've got they're after
him and I'm looking for him and I can
sniff you just follow the trail yeah
that's so funny you know I want to be
that person too but I haven't the type
of skin wear perfume doesn't stick
saying I don't know how to make it say
someone told me off before I tried it I
felt stupid
it didn't work but similar it is good
because okay it's not gonna say I
understand but at least you could bring
it with you and keep putting it on and
then extra spritz in the bathroom
Brits okay best husband a wedding I'm
Tuesday Vinny was chatting with TMZ and
made his best pitch to Kim Kardashian
which by the way the TMZ video cameraman
prompted so it wasn't Vinny's idea oh
just okay I didn't see the video I just
read the headline um who helped in early
prison release of one woman to get
Sorrentino out he said quote Kim Mike is
an amazing person to me he's completely
reformed he's like a great member of
society he preaches to kids that have a
ditch
he's a big advocate and evangelist for
recovery he'd be better off out here
helping people can get on that he
concluded okay
Kim is doing such important work for
prison reform for people who really
[ __ ] need it like sorry at the end of
the day you did evade taxes and you only
want to jail for six months being
grateful for that
do your time you did the crime get out
and then become the reformed person that
you are it's great that you got it
before but you just got it this is the
way the world works you live in America
that's the price you pay
but like Kim is literally working
tirelessly and is getting criticized
from every single person for literally
working hard for people who have been in
jail for twenty thirty years for
literally the tiniest crime like she is
doing important work she need not be
wasting her time with one Mike
Sorrentino no she need not be and in
this situation like the punishment fits
the crime
no no not even like that's not even a
lot of jail time no so like it wasn't
his idea to make this big no Tim Zee
associated with the green himself but
like if I were him I would have been
like no he'll be out in eight months I
go spend your time doing more important
things I couldn't agree more and more
worthier cause and I was churning out
content and merch while he is behind
bars she follows Instagram no he
released like a line of like merch
before and like they're still promoting
it like I'm sure his wife is doing it
it's like free snitch ifer the rest free
snitch mirth I prefer free Luanne March
uh I prefer free Marissa March totally I
just finished öthey and and oh my
thoughts have changed now as being an
adult who's in tune with what's
necessary first of all like everyone
thought the show and did one where I
said I'd like no she was the worst
character like show began the show began
when she died it would be like a Carrie
Bradshaw died on said Oh finally we
could journal a dream and it was like
when we watching the show she put
herself in so many dangerous situations
because she was so [ __ ] stupid
that this was bound to happen up
suppressed you didn't die earlier and
when they do that flashback episode
where Ryan comes to Newport as if he
never was there in the first place and
they cease what life would have been
like if he never showed up Marissa would
have died in Tijuana so she got like and
I'm glad they made that case that she'd
be dead no matter how you slice it right
and then someone who used to always
bother me tail
townsend love her the young-sun Kiro
brilliant hilarious does she go in our
basket of people of people who need
justice yes accept okay I'll I'll get my
scissors names always trying to make us
like her and I just said it it felt like
at the time they were just trying to
replace Marissa but she was [ __ ]
we were looking at it all wrong through
the lens of we're placing Marissa where
it's like no she's an incredible
character I don't she will go in the
basket of people who we once hated but
now deserve justice a la Meredith Blake
a la Gaston a la Sharpay Evans exactly
John I'm glad I got that off my chest
makes you and I'm glad that we now have
another addition to our basket because I
love making the basket the MVP of the
show
Oh julie cooper-nichol Julie Cooper yeah
took the show on her back truly and she
was just so underappreciated in that
house that she got yeah but like her
ending kind of bothered me because she
was choosing between two men Ryan's dad
and the bullet who is the best character
ever and she like never really made a
choice and instead went to college we'll
see about that yeah let's get a spinoff
Julie Cooper where's she now like I
would love that
get Oprah's an actress now like that's
Melinda Clark you ever did a lot of the
characters from that show like didn't
really do anything like Kiki here's a
mom yeah what did she do
oh but the grandfather is now on dynasty
he literally is a cat has nine lives I
know and now I always thought I would
never see him as anything other than
Caleb Nichol but then when I was
reacting Oh see like you really do hear
his accent and he really is what's his
name
Alan doe no in the in dynasty Oh with an
a Andrews are you cut off - yes the
greatest show of all time the greatest
show of all time the greatest Wardrobe
of all time and the greatest set
designer of all time and the greatest
makeup artist for Liz Gillies cuz who
the hell does her eyeliner the greatest
wardroom falls had my follow the
wardrobe stylist uninstall that's so
smart like I just love seeing her stuff
and yeah post like inspo pictures and I
just want to know what she's inspired by
right cuz I'm gonna marry her who
inspires your inspiration well let's
think
my inspiration is Andy coming and he's
inspired by like Susan Lucci so I don't
really relate to that but you know
yeah he's inspired by soap opera stars
from the eighties okay next up cardi B
Las Vegas residency announced at the
Palms Casino Resort Vegas is just like
coming out strong cardi B is headed
since
on Wednesday the Palms Casino Resort
announced the bow dock yellow rapper
will kick off her first residency this
spring at Kao s a day Club and nightclub
slated to open in April as part of the
hotel's six hundred and ninety million
dollar renovation they made a car D
joint gez cascade and Skrillex among
additional performance with performers
who will have residency's at the club
the venue also reportedly features a
rotating 360 degree DJ booth vomit ya
know I've been there dates will be
announced Wednesday ok ok I just think
like if we need to just relax on the
word presidency because it's beyond
confusing like when florida georgia line
had a residence he did three shows like
or six shows in Vegas that's not the
same are you there for five years then
it's a residency did you watch daily pop
yesterday no because that was their
exact point oh and I wondered what I
would have said I would have said about
this she's too young to have horizon to
see she doesn't have enough in her
Catalan put another album she's held a
Jew in like a month of shows she's doing
like every other Friday in Vegas it's so
stupid like and then you see an murder
text me Las Vegas residency for cardi B
and I was like oh my god but then I'm
like what and then it makes sense she's
not actually doing a residency Celine
Dion five shows a week for five years
she's doing a show like a couple
concerts she's doing like a tour
basically or putting tour sets I don't
know but then they were saying on daily
pop I wonder what I would have thought
of this story if I hadn't watched it
done first me too
they were saying that she is gonna do
Vegas it's really good money and it's
easy money and you base it it's like you
don't have to travel that much it's
honestly better than touring and if you
live in LA she's getting too comfortable
there and gonna stay there too long as
so many people do and like not focus on
new music because she could keep doing
this but know if she does that kind of
like people go there to retire right but
so who else has done that at too early
of an age no no one else but like
Britney Deena residency she stayed on
for like five years right and it was
time like she needed to retire right
same with Celine same with Backstreet
Boys like it's time yeah but it's not
time for cardi B exactly so I just hope
she doesn't get too comfortable meet you
is all I'm saying
yeah I would have that biggest money mmm
there's so much money in Vegas yeah and
none of it belongs to me next story
Yolanda Hadid denies Bella and Gigi have
gotten plastic surgery lol the hadith
family is full of natural beauty
last week Yolanda Hadid revealed on
Instagram that she was done with plastic
surgery for good following complications
that exacerbated her Lyme disease quote
living in a body free of breast implants
fillers botox extensions and all the
[ __ ] I thought I needed in order to
keep up with what society conditioned me
to believe what a sexy woman should look
like until the toxicity of it all almost
kill me beauty is a social construct
that's for damn sure
for damn [ __ ] sure commenters quickly
pointed out that Hadid starters Bella
and Gigi are both rumored to have gone
under the knife quote I agree with you
but what about your daughter especially
Bella she's beautiful but must use
fillers one fan wrote and she is in the
modelling business so how do you
rationalize that Yolanda shut it down
immediately quote none of my children
have never done fillers or Botox or put
anything foreign in their body weight
it's a double negative the message is
true maybe I mean either it's it's an
inner type of other fruit or it was like
a Taylor Swift like they they know
better after seeing what I went through
alright I do believe that Yolanda take
took out everything I don't think she
gets fillers anymore I don't think she
gets Botox anymore I think she really
does live this clean free natural
holistic life but to just blatantly lie
to people is not nice I mean you don't
have to be a [ __ ] scientist or a
surgeon to see that Bella Hadid is a
completely different face right you
don't have to be dr. Co for Eman to see
two different noses and yes people's
faces changes they grow up but your nose
your nose does not literally change
shape and it's just mathematically when
you are as skinny as someone like Bella
or Gigi is like they weigh what probably
like 105 pounds like they're so small
your face would have to be like John's
gay little jaunt but they get fillers so
they can have these skinny skinny bodies
but like these lively almost chubby
poofy faces so that they look fresh and
healthy so there's no way to do that
other than getting like fat injected
into your face so I mean this is just
this is a categorically untrue statement
but maybe it's not because you did use a
double negative maybe she was just you
know being strictly tricky she or she
said it and she ate her fingers crossed
that I interact totally no my daughters
have never had any plastic surgery her
toes are crossed I'm wearing that
crossing it was like I would cross my
eyes to a big Lacroix I was such a loser
you cross two hands that cran chose each
other out but yeah and then they cross
both but then your toes are crossed and
your eye
okay my hair are crossed over oh yeah
and it's like you could just lie all the
time
totally okay next right again breezy
easy breezy beautiful breezy Billups
that's funny fun thank you
you should on tour okay get the double
up girls no job no comma wait did want
to make an announcement thank you so
much
I'm yesterday the general public sale
for my tickets in Dallas went on sale
and presale you guys really [ __ ]
knocked it out the park love you so much
but there are a bunch of tickets left
it's just no bi p left and then we're
announcing a new Greenville South
Carolina show and a new Houston show in
a couple days so you should be a picture
member because you get presale
availability and I have some shows being
announced maybe next week on the what
people say the best coast also known as
the west coast so for those who've been
hounding me a lot Ollie Mohajir I'll see
you there
that's exciting yeah it is Mick's story
is also exciting what Anna Wintour
really thought of Megan Markos wedding
dress how do we know because she has
issuing a new digital series called go
ask Anna where like someone in the
office House of sir question like a bug
tries so hard with other digital series
this is an incredible idea for ten years
ago you know on like people don't care
about boab these two I mean sorry about
Anna Wintour anymore like think the
reason they care about bug is because
they want to see like Gigi and Kendall
like doing their makeup and Rihanna and
like they have some early and they have
some good [ __ ] I want to see beyond I
don't want to see Gigi and Kendall girls
who don't wear makeup and don't need to
ya know I want to see the highly doing
her makeup right like people who take it
on yeah not oh I use this little rosy
tint and like people who don't even wear
foundation looks thing I just will cut
yeah or like put on like concealer with
their fingers I can't same or like
people who are like I just wear a little
sunscreen or like we used like a tinted
chapstick as their lipstick you know
like I just can't believe she's like
screaming on their lips or cheeks and
their eyeshadow yeah out of control yeah
and the clear brow gel and they're all
sponsored so it's like whatever product
they are using and they're being paid to
you to your beauty we even use it
Neutrogena
totally anyways any whant or let the
world know how she really thoughts about
Megan margles bridal gown
say during an episode of a video series
called go ask Anna the video featured
the vogue editor-in-chief answering
questions from people she'd never met
Wow
the questioner wanted to know the
fashion icons thoughts on the Dutchess
of Sussex I'm the Duchess of Sussex
period looking back on the Royals big
day and hers Vontae dress went or
described Megan's wedding dress choice
as quote brilliant quote it was
sophisticated it was chic it was
grown-up went or said we're calling
Claire wait Keller's design quote it was
an English designer albeit one that was
working for a French house which in a
way was a message to the world yes I'm
from somewhere else but I belong in
addition to a plot II know you know I
don't think that was the message in
addition to applauding the quote
fantastic look Wintour appraised Megan
for walking down the aisle by herself as
royal and at as royal admirers will or
will recall wow this is really hard it
would all be it right yeah Megan made
the trip solo before meeting up with
Prince Charles and having him escort to
heard the rest of the way to Prince
Harry the Prince of Wales stepped in
after Megan's father Thomas Merkel was
no longer able to perform after losing
his cut oh my god that's so funny
obviously Anna Wintour's trying to get
Megan on the cover cuz she's so [ __ ]
far / as she's about to come out of her
mouth right honestly here for Megan on
the cover and the more that I am a bride
and I've shopped for wedding dresses now
and made the rounds and not even like I
probably looked been to the store like
three times the more I disliked Megan's
dress and the more disappointed I am by
it and the more I don't understand the
choice well which one the first one the
first rugs the second was nothing to
talk about in the second one like yeah
it wasn't the dress moment we got one
picture but like the moment the picture
that will was heard around the world is
from the day ceremony and I don't
understand how it happened like that to
me it's like the dress wasn't even so
bad it was fine it was very British and
it was very royal and it was very like
plain and boring and that's what the the
Royals are I just the unforgivable part
is how poorly terribly tailored it was
who are they though with such an amazing
body like poorly ironed or not at all if
they dress itself like I have I take
umbrage with but if it was made to fit
and looked perfect probably would have
been a lot but I wanted the simplicity
but between like the just dry-cleaning
your lack there
and then the dress itself like that now
I have to question the whole thing yeah
no I agree
and by the way Ana like but you know how
like sometimes in like English class you
would be reading a book and it was like
the man walked down the street and
you're like yeah so what and the
teachers like what does it mean I'm like
well he was going somewhere obviously no
he's gonna kill himself
like he's like crazy this is what Ana is
it was a British designer from France
and therefore Megan was telling the
world that she's an outsider from
another country nope she just liked the
designer and the designer happened to be
born in another country sometimes it's
just coincidence Anna sometimes my
English teacher dr. Gaylord he would
always say like it's a penis what it's
an apple like I just don't understand
that's why I like I will never be like
into school or like scholarly and like I
really am much more like a street smart
because like all the things like I mean
I've said this on the show before when
were reading Hamlet I'll never forget
this we were reading Hamlet and they
said something and he was like what does
it mean and I'm like he's done and this
girl matica Vito raised her hand she was
like he wants to [ __ ] his mom and I was
like hey yeah and he was like correct
you know what like that's what I was
like I don't understand literature like
whatsoever but also you just make
inferences it's like who's the teacher
to tell you unless there's some
encyclopedia that the teachers have of
the hidden meeting no but unless you
left him no to interpretation right and
so I had it like maybe we're all just
disgusting thinking I might want to [ __ ]
his mom and he's just like had a really
great relationship with her totally I
did the opposite thing one time in
school because I was so tired of all
these mother I am having deja but we
have had this conversation right I don't
know if you remember my story but I so I
was so sick like cuz I'm someone you
know I read it and that's what it said
and it is what it is and I'm always
wrong and I even like teachers who tell
me like I don't analyze the text enough
so we're reading Great Gatsby and at one
point guess he's throwing all these silk
shirts around in a huff and Daisy starts
crying and the teacher is like why is
easy crying and I I tried to think out
of the box right because I think you're
stupid when you're taught to do and I
was like she's crying because she's
looking at like the wastefulness of all
these silk shirts and thinking Aveeno
the hard workers who work so hard to put
them together - no way yeah what was it
Adam
you know probably because she's [ __ ]
depressed and nothing was ever good
enough for her a piece of [ __ ] worst
character in history made even worse
that she was played by you know fake
Michelle Williams yeah Phil iums
Michelle feelings by the way like if I
even remotely like knew how to read it
would be really funny if we did like a
toast book club where we read like
classic literature and just like revamp
[ __ ] but surely like I haven't read a
book that's a great another podcast idea
yeah like I haven't read a book like
that wasn't a celebrity tell-all since
high school
no me neither because I didn't do any
other reading in college and I barely
did it I think the last book I read was
in the ninth grade it was the Curious
Incident of the dog well that's why it
was the last book you read it was also
the last play I saw or maybe portrait of
Dorian Gray Gate I gave it a chance yeah
where's your Dorian Gray he's a great
book is it no it's really good
I think it whatever one was complaining
about he was a picture give me no
[ __ ] sense I just don't [ __ ] with
literature like whatsoever I really
prefer reality TV you start a book club
dragon I we can but like I won't read
the books I will do Cliff's Notes and
like please don't give me a pit I had
like but 15 years of pits in high school
doing summer reading and required
reading and assigned reading and I just
I'm now out of it finally please don't
make me go back there okay I'll think
about it
I'll think about it okay okay anyways
Megan's dress very disappointing made
even more disappointing by the fact that
there are just so many dresses she could
have bought off the rack that would have
sat better yeah better and you graph
better there really are like even like
cheap ones expensive ones like all
wedding dresses are really very pretty
yeah like it's hard to find an ugly one
right it's like even when you don't like
someone's wedding dress it's not that
it's ugly it's like oh it was simple it
was plain it was big didn't fit but like
not that it was ugly
you know I'm looking at all these brides
magazines if they want to have me on the
cover and there are so many beautiful
dresses every day I have foam over I
said I'm not wearing yeah no I agree
and she is a perfect body and face yeah
so there's no excuse agreed anyways did
them find a story before we just get to
talk about ourselves some more and get
into Deere toasters because I picked
some and I've been missing me too
little media news that's really speaks
to the digital landscape these days Oh
does it
but BuzzFeed is laying off 15 percent of
the come
the workforce BuzzFeed is laying off 15%
of its workforce about 215 people
sources tell The Hollywood Reporter CEO
Jonah Peretti on Wednesday sent a memo
to staffers with the subject line quote
difficult changes in which he explained
that efforts to diversify revenue
weren't enough to help the company
achieve profitability quote
unfortunately revenue growth by itself
isn't enough to be successful in the
long run run he wrote the restructuring
we are undertaking will reduce our costs
and improve our operating model so we
can thrive and control our destiny
without ever needing to raise funding
again the cuts expected to be
company-wide are set to take place next
week the staff reductions will give
BuzzFeed a faster path to profitability
a spokesperson said rumors started
flying about the layoffs on Tuesday and
the company's New York and Washington
dc-based offices lots of people are
talking about it's an employee on the
basis of anonymity about 1450 staffers
work at BuzzFeed okay honestly like it's
very sad when people get laid off don't
get me wrong but like honestly I hate
everyone who are servos feet and their
dumb videos about cats so like you could
take your cat talents somewhere else I
do have to say they're extremely
wasteful and it comes to like resources
because every day because I follow
BuzzFeed tasty and that's obviously
their most popular account and the one
that makes the most money and that like
has the most engaged audience and they
always use that to like build other
channels and they build some of the
dumbest [ __ ] channels that take like
incredible resources to produce the
content like there was this one like DIY
like how to build a birdhouse like three
[ __ ] craftsmen handyman building a
birdhouse like nobody needs to know to
build a birdhouse you know no it's like
they're serious like throw enough [ __ ]
up against the wall something will stay
yeah they have a little bit that they're
throwing is like millions of dollars
right in cost they have like this little
cupcake who like gives advice and it's
like this animator who probably cost a
lot of money to build these animations
giving you like happy good job like it's
so [ __ ] stupid like no wonder they're
losing money just stick with the cooking
videos and the Gipp reaction lists okay
right well I was reading up on this
yesterday and a bunch of other media
companies hat are going through layoffs
or just like shutting down completely
and then when you think about you know
all of the worst media like the best of
the worst digital media brands out there
in these days like BuzzFeed really is
like number up tier tawdry so it's like
if there
going through it and they're not
profitable and they can't make money and
they're number one what does this mean
for the digital media landscape oh my
god oh you got a panel right now tell us
what does it mean I just think it's
gonna take more independent
entrepreneurial female backed brands
that are really gonna give the people
what they really want
I couldn't agree more you know and it's
really audience driven conversations and
just if there were ever to be like two
women who were really out here doing it
for themselves I think that would really
propel the industry forward you know
that would be nice
that would be nice but to have some
outfit and their due diligence god
forbid
so I just think it was just an
interesting factoid that was well
interesting you know but it's
interesting and it's always sad when
people get laid off but um then I hope
everyone you know finds a job like in
Brooklyn where they live but I think
this is good like I think it's time we
diversified like it's like and they feel
like Huffington Post was that way too
like for a while it was like whatever
but she says is right
whatever happened to post says is right
like now whatever the morning tow says
is right for sure no but it was I don't
know if anyone ever said it if if it's
what the Huffington Post said it's right
no but like it's just considering like
this like media brands would look to
BuzzFeed and write but I mean they can't
even make money why are we looking for
them right that's what I'm saying that's
what a toast is profitable speaking of
new March coming soon um that's why like
there are layoffs I haven't all the time
you don't really report on them and I
found this one to be an extremely
interesting because they're probably
like the pinnacle of like popular media
brands they're like the success story
the small blog about gifs literate
earned into like a huge News Corporation
exam so you know it is interesting and
it's sad cuz but what does this mean for
the digital landscape exactly and as
much as you know the morning toast is
here to solve all of the digital media
landscapes problems we only have so many
what else is the future you know what
the future of digital media like where
do people get their news it's not
Facebook Twitter they're suffering to
know it's like live streams live streams
on YouTube better right [ __ ] yeah that's
I'm saying live streams that maybe that
go live it's Tiger days by the way it is
podcast I was just waiting I was just on
this thing what did I say it was called
pod remember I was like have you heard
of pod nests podcast
oh no whatever it was like this podcast
like news information
thing and they're doing all and like
literally podcasts get like 50 million
views a month
listen listens whatever yeah they need
to come out with digital podcasts like
video podcasts like this yeah like where
you can on the podcast app watch us too
yeah but for some reason people don't
like it like for this show like you can
watch it or you can listen to it and so
many more of you choose to listen to it
yeah but I want to show my face so oh
yeah and you know there are those of you
who are here every morning thank you we
appreciate you
okay so let's jump into your toasters if
you guys don't know dear toasters is our
advice segment where we do loud
unsolicited not-so-great advice no I'm
kidding it's actually really good I'm if
you have something you want advice on
email us at dear toasters DEA RTO a/s te
RS at gmail.com anything from
relationship stuff to wedding stuff to
friends stuff the more interesting and
freaky the better so let's jump right in
shall we
we shall just give me a moment here to
pull up my app you know my electronic
mail do you have an account I do okay
this is called to convert or not to
convert quick background someone posted
in to us after dark about you guys
recording a patreon episode about your
faith and it inspired me to write this
email it inspired a lot of people used
to listen to it my boyfriend and I have
been dating for close to three years and
we have been living together for about
six months and everything is lovely we
aren't getting engaged anytime soon but
I have a feeling that it's going in that
direction he's Jewish I'm not he isn't
super religious he doesn't go to Temple
that often or ever but he participates
and all of the High Holidays so I guess
he considers himself more culturally
Jewish his dad is Jewish and his mom
converted when they got married his dad
was very sore throgs
but he has since become more moderate
his parents had my boyfriend his parents
and my boyfriend and I have had long
conversations about what it means to be
Jewish and they've been great about
educating me on their faith since I have
very little knowledge of it is that
their way of telling me that I need to
convert I've thought about it for a long
time and to be honest I don't think I
want to do it is that disrespectful is
it expected that I convert I have not
yet talked to my boyfriend about it yet
because I want to know what the best way
to go about this is before I say
anything any advice to you guys would be
helpful I'm a little lost lamb please
keep me anonymous wow this is Jennifer
no kidding I have so many thoughts meet
you first of all like no it's not
disrespectful if that's how you feel but
I would
tell your boyfriend sooner rather than
later that's something that he should
know and you'll find out if it's
important to him that you do convert or
not yeah um and if he it is important to
him that you do convert maybe he
couldn't explain to you why in a way
that might change your opinion yeah look
I don't want to proselytize
but being Jewish rocks so like if it's
something that you're open to I would
explore it cuz like then we could be
related but if you talked to me about it
and he's like oh that's fine that
doesn't like it's not important to me
anyway then great Pitts gone no but you
do have to tell it but you might talk
him about it he'd be like it's important
to me for these reasons and then when
you know he makes his case you might
feel differently or he might be like
that's important to me and we can't get
married if you don't and that's
something you should know now right and
for both of you like you're you might
just be wasting your time like some
people they only want to marry someone
of their faith and that's a deal-breaker
and that's fine but you do have to be
honest because now you would have waited
three years yeah of your time so I say
be honest but also explore it why not
yeah look into it I'm out here and I'll
sit on so testing the right word yeah
it's such a hard word to say
proselytizing and then you're like the
act of proselytization like how do you
press little is possibility cessation
from yeah that was at proselytization i
don't know if that's a word
it's it is whenever anything a
proselytize what do you think of one two
three Book of Mormon yeah hello my name
is elder price oh yeah okay that wasn't
so crazy no but I think that was good
advice we gave yeah for sure okay so
yeah honesty is the best policy this one
is but also deny till you die yeah this
one I thought would take a little bit
more of an in-depth analysis so it's
gonna be our final one okay it is titled
my sister wants to [ __ ] our stepbrother
why though dear Claudia and Jackie I am
24 years old at my sister's twenty-one
years old
last summer my mom got me wrapped
remarried to my now stepdad who has
three kids of his own the youngest is 18
years old needless to say the five of us
didn't grow up in the same house we very
rarely even see each other now because
we're all in and out of college go to
separate sides of the family for
holidays I'm writing to you because I
need advice like help my younger 21 year
old sister is snapping flirting and
hinting effort opening up with my
youngest stepbrother who is 18 here's
the thing he's actually like hot he
looks like he's 27 years old plays
football and is just perfect like he's
hot guys like it's almost automatic and
imaginable the kind of hot person that
makes you confused that a kind of person
could look like that I do not know
whether or not to encourage my sister or
and my step-brother to hook up she
genuinely has a crush on him if he
wasn't her stepbrother it's like almost
like we could have met him anyway
dude the amount of mutual friends she
was geography and the circle that we
live in it's almost like my sister in
him would have met anyway she continues
to tell me what if her parents met so we
could meet oh my god that's so funny um
what do you guys think what should I do
it should I just not say anything I want
to support my sister but like is this
wrong or is it just not right does it
stay a secret help I know this is
literally clueless this is clueless I
have so many thoughts on this and who I
blame
Hollywood in every show that's on Gossip
Girl even the OSI the pair the kids date
and the parents date too and it's very
normal and so this is nothing out of the
norm if you watch we just grew up
watching CW like lily and Rufus and
Serena and Dan
oh they got there sits the same
situation okay but so us and Ryan Julia
their parents just got married they
don't have the same mom or dad I know
same with Cher and Josh yeah so like
it's really not that we like it no it's
not weird when it happens in TV shows it
sounds it said weird when you said my
sister wants to fund our stepbrother but
you don't have any of the same DNA okay
well here's the thing if she just wants
to [ __ ] him and like never mention it
again you can't like now no because that
will make holiday so awkward but if you
guys are like in love and like you want
a date then that's kind of cute and
normal but if you break up oh my god
like I don't know it is really terrible
no no if you I feel like there wouldn't
be as weird if like the kids got
together first and then their parents
got married that's like so cute we set
up our parents right but like
technically it's the same level of weird
if it happens the other way now the
other way around is like well now we're
a family so am I gonna [ __ ] my brother I
don't know I think you just need to find
out like does this 18 year old want a
girlfriend because if not it's not worth
it right honestly unless you think it's
the love but the girl unless you think
you're gonna get married and like you
would have to do it soon but the little
sister being like we met they met so we
could meet like it's so precious and
cute but the sisters 21 of the kids 18
like you know the relationship
definitely has its own kind of issues
like any relationship knows why like if
you you eyes either
like get married right now and then it's
not weird but it can't be like dating
your family dinner no honestly like I'm
gonna advise against it unless you think
it's the great love story of our
generation you know right in which bit
like still late they would you can't be
like a family dinner being boyfriend and
girlfriend with your brother I'm not
liking out in front of your like at
family dinner with your husband
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying so
we're like I you guys should just go to
Vegas like get married people on the
YouTube stream please let me know what
you think I'm really feeling they're not
they're not here for they're not being
okay but like I just can't help but
think like what if this was like her one
true love it's possible it does sound
very fate vibes but you know where does
where to see other guys stand like if
they're just snapchatting like that's
just code for like booty call and you
cannot booty call with your stepbrother
I want less you're like an ongoing thing
I don't know we need to check the rest
of that you know there's probably one
from your boy like my sister [ __ ] how do
I tell her no oh man that's so funny my
new stepsister send me really really
weird flirty snapchats
it's 11:11 Mike Wesch joseffer the girls
just as for the girls just as for the
girls just as for the girls just as for
the girls just it's about the girls just
as for the girls just as for the girls
streaming platform streaming platform
treatment wow that's hard streaming
platform streaming Netflix show Netflix
show Netflix show Netflix show Netflix
show I'm a joke we could stream live on
Netflix every morning everyone is
Netflix like watcher anywhere they'd be
cool that would be cool
do they do anything lines no yeah they
don't have a live show morning post live
show I just think there's too many
negative outcomes from this that I am
going to advise against it even if there
is a small chance that he is the one
true love your OTP in addition to the
factors Ilana Carter has stated but
absolutely not because he's 18 he's
probably excited to go to college and
[ __ ] girls yeah there's just too many
awkward outcomes she has to be stopped
okay she sounds so cute and precious so
like I'm just picturing her like I'm the
one in she sounds keen and precious
because she said that one thing but on
the other hand she's like sending
thottie Santos to her brother totally so
I don't know about cute impression
that's like when Josh and Chad were
playing footsie under the table when
they were supposed to be highlighting
briefs right but their parents weren't
married at the time right but they
didn't technically like um this would be
if those parents divorce and then you
guys start dating then it's Sharon Josh
and ask
not weird that's not weird yeah you know
what sorry it's still weird and you know
I
that's something people don't talk about
enough in the movie clueless it's that
great she got her happy ending but she
thought your mother you know know what
also an awesome girl and the I see and
in every other [ __ ] Cho check you
that's such a great point it's Hollywood
poisoning our minds yeah because they're
sick is what we learned so it's really
if Hollywood says it's okay it's
probably not stay far away from your
brother we need to just get this girl on
a dating app hook her up with someone
else
yeah we need to get her mind off of her
bro yeah no we can you know we got to do
like a completed sick mind body makeover
like Taylor Townsend go to the Sorbonne
and get the [ __ ] away from books the
Sorbonne it's in France what does it
needs to go to college in France okay so
that he doesn't have to see her yeah
this girl needs to focus on other things
like maybe find a new hobby like a new a
new soul cycle like a new workout class
something yeah she needs to like kick
off her nice resolutions of just having
hobbies like you know working on herself
a little bit where she meets someone
else and she can use the new map to do
that it's not too late to kick off your
year right stay on track and meet your
new year's resolutions and meet your
goals with noon sticking to a weight
loss plan can be hard especially when
you don't know how to handle the
thoughts and obstacles that hold you
back from making progress or from having
sex with your brother the zoo makes that
really easy with their custom app that
helps you get the help that you need in
order to reach your goals Noom is
designed for results meet your
resolutions by signing up for your trial
today at noon and oom calm slash toast
what do you have to lose visit noon calm
slash chose to start your trial today
again that's Noom dot-com slash toasts
start losing weight for good I'm like
loving tracking all of my progress in
life of the app I know zoom I use dry
January I use my health app and your
period tracker actually don't use a
pareo tracker okay at my planner for
that I used a tracker all through high
school and it was so great but like now
I like every time I do it I like forget
to log it and Margo is always like I'm
36 minutes late I'm like [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] do you know that cuz she tracks
hers like crazy but like I forgot about
it but I need to get back on the
tracking tracking and organization is
just the key to a happy life yeah and it
just helps you know where you're at and
a planner you know that's step one I bet
my connect planner is my very easy
tracking yeah no you're right let's just
put them up
yeah then you'll be like you can count
how many then you think how many DS
between that you usually have between
each period and what was the last trip
we took let me try and think wasn't
because I feel like you were next yeah
no no look together oh you went with
snitch on the road no I'm just trying to
figure out Miami for a living that's
right before no for your chose this time
think when I last time I got my period
was oh I remember cuz I was traveling
and about tampons before my trip okay
good so I'm not gonna have a next week
in Mexico oh right you're going back to
medicine yeah oh my god and I just have
to say I feel like such a [ __ ] trader
but like I'm absolutely head over heels
in love with revolve oh my god I just
ordered another batch of thing I didn't
know what you were gonna say oh really
because so when I was going to Mexico
for my trip last week there was like all
these themed nights it was like a disco
where you had to wear sparkles and an
all-white and I couldn't find anything
to wear I literally ordered everything
possible from gloomy doesn't returned it
and Jackie was like check revolve and
I'm like honestly I sighs out of her
valve but that was like my old mentality
now I probably could do like a revolve
larger where I used to like literally
not even it wasn't even questioned so
Jackie made me go on and we were like
sending each other a million sparkly
things and I ended up getting something
great and so for my Mexico trip this
time I went on again like honestly I I
went to the sale and I ordered cuz like
all the summer stuff is is out but I
need to stuff from Mexico I got like a
million like LPA like all their fake
brands like $30 dresses and they all
okay they're annoying with their size
it's like for regular dresses sometimes
that I saw a dress that only went up to
a size six like that's not fair yeah
like I'm you know I'm like a normal like
eight or ten revolve 12 feels like it's
still revolved yeah but so but now I'm
like I'm getting in unlike the tail end
and now it's motivating me chill I could
be even skinnier it's like the clothes
are so cute and I just like need to fit
into them and it's better than going
shopping at a store and like being
utterly depressed by their lighting and
their selection because they have a
really great return policy and they send
you the label and honestly that's what
it it has evolved no we're not they send
you the label I cannot [ __ ] with
ordering online okay a so sensual label
revolve sensor label Saks Fifth Avenue
does not send you a label and it's like
are you kidding me with your expensive
ass you can't throw our label in also
Bloomingdale's does not throw them I
take it out of your refund 795 what the
[ __ ] is that
and you
you'll have to be the one to go drop it
off at UPS you know I waited my Lobby to
the UPS comes and I sneak it into the
truck I'm like yeah Bloomingdale's it's
like in the Stone Age when it comes to
online orders okay I disagree all this
stuff before I went to the Dominican and
I needed to send back a bathing suit
bottom and they they're whole like
website process to get the return label
I didn't even mind up doing it and then
I ordered the same meetings who got them
in a size smaller and I did like Next
Day Delivery or something and I get an
email the next day your orders been
canceled because we can't we can't
figure it out oh that's crazy well and
it's like don't cancel my order
okay just send it regular and I guess I
won't have it when I hear it I'll have
it they're there in Stone Age but their
delivery ordering online but I don't
know if this is all the stores but the
the main store in New York has the most
amazing like I literally sit at home buy
something and I can get a same-day
delivery to my house I can also I order
so much stuff in bloomingdales online
and I returned 90% of it but like after
a couple weeks I'll put all the returns
in a bag and I'll just go to
Bloomingdale's in return I did that
yesterday I ever turn like maybe 10
things that I'd ordered in the past
month yeah and I didn't even have a
receipt they're great about that like
been literally not to blow up a spot
like Larry will wear a pair of pants a
hundred times like you know I don't like
him anymore nee returns him hit six to
four I like they just take stuff
yes Sephora is great with return yeah I
heard they were changing their return
policy but it hasn't affected me yet I
mean I I literally return stuff is my
worst nightmare and when it comes to
like boo boo boo who does not [ __ ]
sin you a label and like you a price of
the item is the same as the shipping so
you know that's what it is it's like a
six dollar sweater that I'm not gonna
wear honestly I just keep it in my
closet because I have to spend six
dollars on the shipping that it's the
same cost and then I don't have to leave
my house yeah it'd be a fun toy for CEO
yeah totally man that's terrible and I
always end up wearing it like someplace
like to the movies you know yeah yeah
well I'm so glad about my mouth because
like I really enjoyed that man I know
you were like remember that dress that
we wanted for the sparkly night but it
didn't come in time because it was
pre-ordered yeah I got it and I'm gonna
bring it to my next Mexico trip isn't it
so cute oh my god so cute
yeah don't mind my hair so frizzy get a
revolve code that would be helpful yeah
actually it would be helpful because
there's so look I literally play around
i order just throw things in my cart
$1500
excuse me why just take out like six
things and only have five in yeah but
then you know you eat you're getting the
miles for turnin like I literally will
order two sizes
time's yeah and send back the one that
doesn't work also you have the honey
extender right yes the honey what is it
like a plugin that like tension chrome
extension that you put on your browser
so when you're shopping on my right
before you check out you press the honey
button and they scour the internet for
codes
I have never purchased anything from
involved that I didn't get a code for
like honey yeah Wayfarer never gives me
a code yeah I love [ __ ] promo codes
I'm like a promo code Queen yeah and I
used to live doing like clipping coupons
ya know it really is and I used to
literally like scour the earth like
googling boohoo perma got literally this
little extension click it's so great one
of the toasters tell me about it thank
you toasters always helping us Real
Housewives of New Jersey but you know my
god yeah [ __ ] go so I did watch it
last night after the game where I had
had two double margaritas and I was like
a little drunk so I remember most of it
I mean the only thing that really is my
lease is monkeys [ __ ] what happened
at dinner um and as much as I loved her
Jennifer was completely wrong I know and
in pain today because I like her
oh and we have Jennifer and Jackie
coming together Oh February 6th and then
February 13th we Melissa that's so
exciting
yeah because I really like it's a very
interesting season for me because it's
like I'd like everyone and I also
disagree with things that they're doing
it's not like there's just one person
who can do no wrong Erica Jane yeah and
I can't see anyone elses side yeah so
Jennifer was wrong because the jeweller
the jeweller that was so awkward like
that necklace is tainted now Teresa can
never wear the necklace but I mean she
called it ugly like that was so mean
that was so mean and it was such a
thoughtful thing for the girls to do so
it's awful and the way the Jennifer one
to bring it up immediately after she
gets the gift doesn't even let her enjoy
it too in front of Teresa yeah talking
about how they all paid it up for it and
like pricing it was just really [ __ ]
tacky yeah I agree
um and also I eyed when they said one
murmured it and they didn't really
didn't put subtitles but her brother's
jewelry stores in Long Island yes so
there's what we're gonna trek out it's
not that big of a deal it wasn't a
30,000 dollar ring it was probably like
in a thousand dollar necklace no it was
definitely more than that but still like
its split between five people whatever
discount your brother's gonna give them
like it's not worth the gas price to go
to Long Island just know what it is it's
like we're not bargain hunting on a gift
right and then you get and they probably
didn't know that her brother was yeah
and even if they did like he's a jeweler
in Long
like that doesn't it like it's like Oh
like it's like if they got plastic
surgery and they didn't yeah her husband
no it was so stupid like and she really
overreacted and went why all Risa Marge
shouldn't have said the thing about her
lip liner looking like a monkey's
[ __ ] because that that takes an
argument about something else and makes
it like personal and light but because
up until that point like Jennifer was in
the wrong and Martin like but Marge met
her there yeah monkeys [ __ ] above his
[ __ ] Jenny were probably focused on I
literally Ben was dying I was in shock
I'm watching Melissa like that would be
the NAPLAN I can't even deal when
someone sends their food back I'm like
oh my job a monkey's [ __ ] that you
probably [ __ ] sucked
and usually in a housewife dinners on
vacation they're in like a private room
they were in the middle of the
restaurant it's like they knew [ __ ] was
gonna go down right so now both Jennifer
and Marge are in the doghouse even but
Marge was so right like could Danielle
be more transparent like the second Jen
gets up deal isn't really no Jen she
like runs to her to talk [ __ ] about
Marge and then Melissa who who was it Oh
Jackie was like marching there's on Jin
Ryu he's like that was funny but the way
that the the teams have divided is like
so obvious like with the rooms even like
it's so weird
Teresa like it weirdly is like stuck on
this side just because she's so loyal to
Danielle they have a weird friendship
well whoever said like this is like
Jackie said having Danielle's back like
this is her way of apologizing and
making up for ruining her life ten years
ago I agree with 100% um
Dolores is like firmly in the middle
right and I like Diloreto
Margaret said that Teresa is a bad judge
of character and then everyone like
would set it as if it's like a known
seaman that made me like go back and
think like because Teresa is the og of
New Jersey sheets kind of like Vicki
Gunvalson in the sense of like if you
don't get along with her like you're not
gonna stay on the show but she always
trees always like immediately lets in
new people as opposed to Vicki who's
just like anti new yeah totally so I
kind of like now thinking about her as a
bad judge of character like in general
it just made me think of everything
differently cuz you wouldn't think that
she is because she's very like nice to
everyone and protective of her inner
circle and let people in but then she
also does like judge him know Jennifer
and like and share mother yeah but there
she her and Jennifer connected
is cherisa was hating Jackie and then
Jennifer started hating Jackie so they
had something to talk about right but
that doesn't make someone like your
friend you know but in our world it
actually does right but so I just
thought it was interesting I'm I'm I was
very interested I know ideally what I
was thinking of the rooming situation
like how would you have done it like she
really did a perfect job cuz it was
there was nobody else for Danielle to
room with maybe Jennifer but like
Jennifer's knew and they really don't
know each other could have got in her
own room and Teresa could have room with
Dolores oh yeah I think I'll goes crazy
if she's alone no and I think there's
something weird with Danielle Teresa
going on it's like a Leeanne Locken
Cameron Cameron Wescott vibe yeah it was
a great episode I just
I think Jersey is so good it's so good
what happens next week look even better
yeah what happened uh Margaret and
Danielle go at it Danielle starts
talking about Margaret's kids and she
throws wine on her oh yeah anybody has
thing else back in that instance I'm
gonna be so [ __ ] pissed because how
many times do these women have to say
stop bringing up the kids hanging out
like that kids are off Jackie wrote
about Jennifer limits and then Jackie
said it to Teresa right and Danielle's
gonna go there even worse go there and
if anyone has seen else back I'm I'm out
ya know like this is where housewives
like in order to win the housewives like
and you want to be involved but also not
be a bad person
you have to like they turn arguments
about random things into something about
completely I was like soundtrack about
the argument fight about the text
messages that you sent after the wedding
don't start ready to let the kids right
and like despite about the brother
jeweler don't sorry talkin out among
Michael even though like that will go
down in history as like truly like an
iconic moment I don't know if Jennifer
is gonna be on the show again I don't
know how long her career on house price
is gonna be but I do know that like
she's forever instilled in the book of
life in terms of housewives just for
that one [ __ ] line and that's what I
said I liked about her it's like if
someone told me my lips before your lips
look like a monkey's ass what like your
reaction would probably be like oh yeah
be like you know cuz you [ __ ] look at
monkeys [ __ ] no like something but
you never know what she's gonna say
and I just I think that's an interesting
element to add to the Housewives whereas
usually it's pretty addictive I like
cookie cutter fights you she said he
said she said yeah but like you [ __ ]
sucked a monkey's ass well also she like
a lot of the times is very reserved and
like conservative and just like as a
family man and then she gets a drink
and like she's insane and I love it no
you know I can't figure her out she's so
unpredictable she's so unpredictable you
think she's one way like she's very
rooted in her culture and her family and
being a mom and a wife and then she goes
Scavo and she's a whole nother person
it's not even like she wakes up the next
day like oh my god what did I do it's
like this is who I am
yeah this is me she has dual personality
words hurt you that's Missy Elliott Oh
fun song would you ever perform on your
own wedding like walk yourself down the
aisle that's something I wish I did if I
had the chops yeah no not as I walk down
the aisle because there's a lot going on
I don't want to be dished like I just
it's a visual thing it's not an audio
thing it's not like a sensory experience
no it's not a podcast I'm on the morning
toast is playing oh my god that would be
so epic I'll record like a little live
show it's morning toast live show it's
morning toast live Wow
did you do live show it's Ronnie toast
live show it's funny to us live but at
the Knicks game last night when they had
Billy and Alec on this you know so when
there's celebrities I think Nick came
and they announced that they're there
they put on the screen like a clip of
their movie or their TV show like a very
popular one but they needed one of them
together and they put the scene from 30
rock when they're in the episode
together and it was like I just wanted I
wanted to leave the game and go watch 30
rock I said why not always does
okay I think that's all she wrote but
that lady's singing so it's over thanks
for being here guys we'll be back
tomorrow with Ryan heard we'll drop a
picture on our Instagram and make sure
leave a comment for him and then next
week what's next week I think I'm here
every day
but Friday okay figure it out um yeah
that's all we got thanks for being here
you guys love you so much thanks for
that support
make sure to listen to the morning shows
every day the Millennial morning show we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube and them are
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found we will see you
tomorrow morning have a wonderful day
tried to say a lot
you